potter the unauthorized harry experience
will have you falling off your
broomstick with laughter
the show is back at valleys and here to
tell us all about it are the stars we
got nicholas charles
and james edwards guys it's great to see
you
first off those who are not familiar
with the show tell what is it all about
tell us what it's about
yeah hi guys thanks for having us on um
the show is
basically all seven harry potter books
in 70 minutes
um so you don't really have to be a fan
of the show
you can have read one book you can have
read all seven seen all the movies but i
promise there'll be something in the
show for you
okay i'm i'm that guy i'm gonna be i'm
that guy i have not seen any of the
harry potter movies but i've heard
such great things about the show so
you're telling me i'm going to walk in
there and you're going to entertain me
for those 70 minutes
oh exactly yeah that's i mean it's it's
all entertainment
once the show starts i mean it does not
stop uh it's it's all seven books
crammed into 70 minutes
and it's just the two of us yeah we got
to stay inside yeah
it's just the two of you guys what
characters do you cover in the show
well so james plays harry potter and i
have the task of taking on
every other role in the books which i
think if you've got your calculator out
it would be about 350 people
how does that work where james you're
just doing harry potter and then then
you're doing all 350 other characters
yeah it's it's really unfair man i have
the easy job
and uh nick he's he's just sweating
buckets
it's a lot of wigs and hats and costume
changes i think there's one part in
book five where we go through about 20
characters in about a minute and a half
we're watching some footage of the show
and you guys are highly entertaining
have you changed anything since prior to
the pandemic
yeah so uh we used to do a segment in
the show where we played quidditch with
the audience
and that is still featuring the show but
we've changed that a little bit
because of you know how covert conscious
people are
we don't particularly want to bring
people on stage at the moment if they're
not comfortable
so instead of just singling a couple of
people out like we used to
we take the whole audience on a
quidditch adventure
which we're calling the 3d quidditch
experience so if you come to the show
you'll be safe sitting in your seat but
you will get to partake in a live game
of quidditch
we love it we love that the show was
back thank you for joining us fellas we
appreciate it
check out potted potter at valleys and
get your tickets online at
pottedpotter.com
and make sure to follow them on all
social media just search
potted pottery